Happy Thanksgiving everybody
you know today maybe turkey day but one
thing that's not a turkey is the movie
arrival it's actually really good but
it's got some complicated subject matter
in it like physics linguistics and
science in general
naturally I found myself really confused
at parts even drooling all over myself
so after the movie I called up my old
friend dr. Clifford V Johnson to come
down and learn me about the movie
science of arrival so get ready to
gobble gobble up some knowledge
it's my esteemed pleasure to have with
us our old friend and generous guest dr.
Clifford V Johnson professor of physics
at USC it's you who are generous for
having me own again you are here to talk
to us about the movie science of arrival
what did you overall think of the
science in the film I think they made
some interesting choices as usual with
these sorts of things they took a nugget
of very interesting scientific ideas and
pushed them somewhat extremely in
certain directions but in a way that I
felt was was fine for the point of view
of we're here to enjoy ourselves the
ship seems to change gravity not in only
the way it travels but within the ship
is this kind of thing possible not the
we know of gravity is extremely
difficult to manipulate because it's
very weak so you need a lot of mass so
you'd be using lots of mass to move
things around but you know what's great
yeah it's completely irrelevant to the
rest of the movie which is why I was
happy for it to be in there so we had a
theoretical physicist who did new
physics no physics and we had a linguist
so talk to me what were your thoughts
about the way the scientists you are a
scientist correct I believe I am how are
the scientists portrayed first of all it
is so refreshing to have a situation
like this be about a linguist trying to
learn how to communicate is probably a
best shot of figuring out difficult
situations here on earth and of course
if we were ever visited
now that's a proper introduction it is
usually important to see linguistics up
there the other great film from recent
times the Martian yes talked a lot about
botany and biology being very important
in the space context I think this is
huge progress in filmmaking these
various disciplines yeah there's other
science are going to be necessary for
further exploration here's the problem
though they felt as filmmakers that in
order to make the point I just made they
needed to push down the other
disciplines oh that is a mistake there's
one point where they go oh the aliens
don't seem to understand algebra so
let's not even try communicating with
mathematics that's ridiculous you don't
build ships like that right
without new being able to do algebra
make sure the one thing we know that's
universal are in in this entire universe
at with that we live in is mathematics
and and the next physics okay so it
makes sense as we've seen another in
another in other films and in other
explorations it makes sense that one of
the first things you would do is try and
see whether you can reach common ground
using you know do you understand prime
numbers things like that and they just
dismiss that out of hand I would have
said they could have kept that there but
gone okay fine we get that we all prime
numbers are great yeah but we still want
to talk about some important stuff we
still need linguistics we need to
communicate emotion we to communicate
all those other things
fish mathematics is not going to do for
us the other thing that I felt was not
so great about the portrayal of the
scientists is that the theoretical
physicist was shockingly ignorant in
terms of his understanding of how other
disciplines work yes it was rather poor
scientists are usually better educated
about what other fields of science do
Jeremy Renner's character was a real
dunce I feel that was not the characters
fault he was at the behest of the
writers yes let's move into some more
spoiler
okay heavy questions so yeah we're going
to talk a little bit in depth about the
film right now uh you know put on pause
go see the movie come right back
there you go the idea of the fourth
dimension has been around for a while
how plausible is the idea of
experiencing time in a nonlinear way as
portrayed in the film we understand a
lot about what it isn't but we don't
know what it is yet
gotcha so that gives artists filmmakers
etc freedom to have some fun they're
taking the nugget of the idea that time
is partly an issue of perception and
partly an issue of your own States of
motion and they're really just blowing
it open and having fun so there's a
nugget of truth which is then expanded
for dramatic purposes oh yeah we
experience time linearly in the sense
that every moment is a pearl on our
string of pearls there you go that's
beautiful
oh thanks great yeah every moment that
we live in our life from birth there's a
pearl for every moment right so string
of pearls right just there it is yes now
take that string of pearls and you
several things that happen two strings
of pearls that normally we can't deal
with very well for example you get it
all tangled up you sort of loop loop it
around oh no my girl Sally you make a
little loop in the middle right
so you have what we would call a closed
timelike curve okay the Pearl example is
great because you could also just put
the pearls in the bag shake it around
still on the string pull it out and you
get this tangle right so so this bit
gets connected to that bit and that bit
gets connected to that bit what have you
it's not it's not linear anymore it's
nonlinear in fact maybe they're saying
that we just simply experience time in
this linear way even though it may not
be that way it may be tangled up may be
time isn't even the thing that we think
of as time maybe it's not anything more
than an illusion and so they have
somehow broken out of that illusion and
they're able to teach us how to do that
at the end of the film dr. amy adams
solves the crisis by getting information
from the future is this a paradox or
does it hold up potentially for you it
isn't you have the usual linear
structure that we're used to and then
you
make a little loop and go back and then
everything else is okay I think what
they're saying is the whole linear
structure isn't really there so if
you're wedded to the linear structure of
time we're just going to netting
right or if you know you're you know
very closely involved in relationship
then you're going to from that
perspective worry about paradoxes yes
but if it's all tangled up string of
pearls all tangled up and what-have-you
then there is no which came first and
then what happened and cause and effect
need to be completely re-examined those
events that we saw that collection of
events spread over time in the various
ways they just are and they're connected
together in the way that they're
connected together and there is no
beginning middle or end define for our
audience again what a paradox is it's
two people with PhDs but that's an old
joke yeah sorry Oh paradox we see in the
film that dr. louise banks can see the
future but she's powerless to change it
does that mean there's no free will the
solution to the paradox is that you just
don't have those choices anymore it's
sort of to do with the issues of if you
had knowledge about what is going to
happen it might make you do things now
that would change those things that are
going to happen and therefore you
wouldn't do the thing that would make
the change
are we presupposing that amy adams dr.
louise banks couldn't it just been like
oh i see that i'm gonna hook up with
jeremy renner screw that i want someone
with real superpowers not drake arrows
yeah
sorry hawkeye I'm washing my hair that I
sorry cut-price born I want to talk for
a second about the sapir-whorf
hypothesis which puts forth the theory
that people think differently depending
upon what language they're thinking in
does it seem possible as stated by the
movie that if someone thought or dreamt
in an alien language it could rewire
their
main to perceive time differently it's
the business of taking a very
interesting nugget of an idea which is
still being discussed in the field of
linguistics and Beyond and and then
pushing it to a narrative extreme for
dramatic purposes so yes I think
everyone would agree and you've probably
yourself had some experience of that
when you've I don't know gone visiting a
different country when you're trying to
look at the world through the language
that you're now speaking or trying to
speak you see it a little differently so
what happens is that you end up perhaps
getting somewhat of the worldview of the
language and the culture it came from
things like that so this is going well
beyond that this is saying that actually
it changes things in you physiologically
and so people discuss that and test that
presumably in their own scientific ways
the film is going way beyond that it's
saying that our perceptions of the
physical world itself at the fundamental
core of it
so how time and space fit together are
also functions of our language and as
such if we found the right language
could change that in some really
significant way now that's really
extreme but it's a fun thing to play
with overall how does this film stack up
with other time-travel theories you've
seen in other movies you ask a difficult
question because they're two stacks
there's the alien encounter stack and
there's the let's play with time stack
yeah the time travel aspect of this is
not um delineated enough that you could
call it silly or not silly it's
provocative in its in it you know the
ideas it plays with so I just can't I
can't rank it in that sense so I'd
rather put it in the alien encounter
pile where does it rank on the scheme of
alien encounter films pretty highly I
would say I guess amongst the favorites
people mention of the serious ones as it
were Close Encounters alien contact in
terms of recent ones I would say it's
it's in the top three of the
contemporary ones I've seen in a long
time Wow that's impressive
and you know what else is impressive you
sir dr. Clifford V Johnson thanks again
for coming in and putting up with my
nonsense
see you next time perhaps indeed mmm-hmm
all that movie science was delicious I'm
thankful to dr. Clifford V Johnson for
coming down here and sharing his
knowledge with us hey what are you
thankful for let us know in the comments
section below also I'm doubly thankful
to you for watching screen junkies have
a great Thanksgiving everybody
hit me up on Twitter bye bye hey guys
did you know that this end card works
with your phone now I know right click
the boxes below to watch more screen
junkies videos and click the screen
junkies logo to subscribe and get this
show honest trailers movie fights and
more